monsieur bonsoir pendant que le public
passe le week end à brégançon retour aux
sources pour son premier ministre
raymond barre est arrivé aujourd'hui
dans son île natale la réunion un petit
bout de france perdue au large des côtes
malgaches à presque une dizaine de
milliers de kilomètres de paris raymond
barre a longtemps vécu là bas mais il
n'était pas revenu à la réunion depuis
cinq ans et pourtant sa mère et même sa
grand mère vivent encore là bas voilà
pour l'anecdote mais au delà des
considérations sentimentales il y à ses
propos du premier ministre propos que
les réunionnais semble êtes-vous pas
tendre à l'exception de ceux qui prônent
l'indépendance ou l'autonomie de l'île
et qui d'ailleurs ont manifesté
aujourd'hui le problème de
l'appartenance à la réunion de la
réunion à la république française ne se
pose pas a dit raymond barre en posant
le pied à la rue est
venu
il avait visité l'élevage ou la voit une
façon de dire aux réunionnais ils sont
des français comme les autres n'a pas
testé que cette visite lui était serre
de plus sa mère l'a tant
il serait même venu plus tôt at il dit
si les devoirs de sa charge lui en avait
laissé le temps à ses compatriotes de
l'océan indien il n'a laissé aucun doute
son retour à la réunion
c'est un retour en france
vous n'êtes pas 500 milles réunionnais
perdu dans l'océan indien
ussel 500 1000 et 55 millions de
français
la france qui a relevé un défi volet pas
aussi celui là
ces départements d'outre-mer mieux
encore que des départements à part
entière des départements témoins la
réunion c'est la france dans l'océan
indien
le premier ministre n'est pas venu pour
nier les difficultés mais pour tenter de
les résoudre avec l'aide de la
population
il y a des efforts à faire ici mais des
progrès ont été réalisés et le
département selon raymond barre soutient
la comparaison parfois avantageusement
avec des départements de la métropole le
premier ministre a tenu à préciser qu'il
est venu sans idées toutes faites et en
solutions miracles il fera le tour des
difficultés avec les élus locaux et on
sait ici que rien ne sera laissé au
hasard raymond barre et précédée par une
solide réputation
coppel fra ensemble depuis la 6ème
jusqu'au bas et les biens publics comme
tous ceux qui étaient avec lui et
j'étais c'était un bon camarade je vais
fêter la vie chère
sadie à kipé dans thema sunrise il
fallait qu'il soit premier est
d'ailleurs il a eu l'excellente et puis
la rivière le suivant pilot il a vu là
il a eu d'excellents le réunionnais
raymond barre a pris quelques minutes
dans son emploi du temps chargé pour
retrouver sa maison natale partie
étudiants pour la métropole c'est un
premier ministre que regarde sa famille
aujourd'hui à la fenêtre